outside a New York courthouse protesters
greeted the former president with signs
warning that he is about to face some
consequences as Donald Trump arrived the
media watching from above and in the
courtroom a scowling Trump waiting to
testify under oath the New York attorney
general Su saying the Trump organization
inflated the value of its real estate to
get better bank loans arguing that
earned the company 100 million and
exaggerated Trump's wealth by $2 billion
before he takes the stand I am
certain that he will engage in name
calling and
taunts and race
baiting and call this a Witch Hunt a
prediction that came true just moments
later these are political operatives
that I'm going to be dealing with right
now you have a racist attorney general
who made some terrible statements judge
Arthur andoran has already ruled that
his company's financial documents were
filled with fraud the question now what
will it cost Trump his family and his
company while his adult sons also his
codefendants testified that their
accountants were to blame Trump
acknowledged that he suggested some real
estate values under questioning Trump
repeatedly fought with the judge who
will ultimately decide his punishment
the state wants him to pay $250 million
in fines and for Trump and his sons to
be banned from doing business in New
York which could mean he would have to
sell some of his most celebrated
buildings during a break Trump motioned
to be quiet advice he may soon wish he
took on the stand Patty khane Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer